foreign
cosmology that has been developing over
the past several years is because
increasingly the big Bang's predictions
are being contradicted by better and
better data
the situation in the past few years has
become so extreme that in the published
literature the predictions are in
contradiction with at least 16 separate
data sets and are only in agreement with
one the deuterium abundance
this situation has been made much worse
over the summer as the spectacular
images from the James Webb Space
Telescope have become available
among other problems the Space Telescope
has shown images that were surprisingly
small surprising to Big Bang
cosmologists
and if taken in the context of the Big
Bang hypothesis imply impossibly small
galaxies with the mass and Luminosity of
our own Milky Way but with 100th the
radius impossible to develop into
present-day large galaxies
in contrast
the alternative which is an evolving but
not expanding Universe has made a
sequence of correct predictions
including our prediction of Ricardo
escarpa and mine of the exact size of
the jwst images before the images were
available
the problem of the James Webb Space
Telescope is a problem I know very well
and when we are about to think speaking
I would argue that most of those results
are not robust and they are strongly
model dependent so there is at the
moment not such a thing as a galaxies
older than the universe
in fact I think they published their
paper far too quickly and I'm not the
only one thinking that and I exactly
calculate the masses of galaxies which
is not the data it's not an observable
it comes out of a detailed modeling
procedure so one thing is data that you
see in astrophysics most of data
actually are filtered by other models so
we need a second layer procedure science
is about predicting things before they
happen since we're talking about an
observational science in which we're
observing things we can't experiment
with we're talking about predicting
observations before they occur
now what's been happening with the Big
Bang Theory is you have an observation
that contradicts a prediction
quantitatively and this was true for
example with the discovery of the
microwave background it was predicted to
be 50 degrees K it turned out to be
three degrees K well that's an error of
about a factor of ten thousand in energy
it's a little off but they adjusted the
theory inflation was another adjustment
because the original theory of this
Cosmic migraine background they figured
out would not give an even sky but one
that was completely uh Hopscotch so they
had to add inflation too
tweak the theory
well
the difference between making
predictions beforehand and making
adjustments after hand is sort of like
this if you're getting on an airplane to
go across the Atlantic and the airline
says well we've had 16 crashes out of
the last 17 flights but after each crash
we were unable to totally understand why
the plane crashed
but you say the next plane crashed and
they said yes well I don't think any of
us would get on that Airline
that's why we have to abandon the big
bang I think everyone is Keen to abandon
the theory if there is a better
alternative
nobody is married to the Big Bang Theory
and also there are different levels that
get mixed together here not necessarily
inflation dark matter and dark energy
if there is a better theory that can
explain the web structure of the
Universe on the larger scale the
distribution of galaxies and I insisted
the fact that the Spectra gets younger
approximately but I think we will all be
fine with that to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit iai.tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas